Superman is fighting Godzilla and it is
dope check this out so basically this
opens up with like Superman flying to
meet Godzilla and the question's got to
be asked why are they even fighting in
the first place to sum this up in like
10 seconds because you guys don't really
care all that much basically the Legion
of Doom like the anti- Justice League in
DC Comics was doing some Shenanigans and
accidentally brought Godzilla and Kong
and a whole bunch of Kaiju into the main
DC Universe like it matters Godzilla
could just materialize out of thin air
and we would be fine anyway Godzilla
just arrives in Metropolis now the cool
thing about this right like once
Superman sees him he's like okay I don't
know if you can understand me or even be
reasoned with at all but your presence
is a danger to the people of metropolis
and we can't have that so let's take
whatever this is somewhere else and
Godzilla just kind of looks at right and
rightfully so because it's like Godzilla
it's not like he doesn't understand it's
more just like are you worth my time
guy in red pajamas underwear right like
should I waste my time with you but then
like as Superman continues to talk
Godzilla starts to fire up that Atomic
breath right now he doesn't even get the
breath off he doesn't even get like the
atomic blast off right Superman's like I
know what's coming bow right just like
Cole Coxs this guy just boom but it's
not enough to knock him out right
because like it's literally like okay
the the fight is on right like the
battle is on right Superman comes
swooping back into the offense boom gets
smacked by Godzilla's tail gets sent
flying through a building only for the
flash to show up and just be like hey
man so like do you need any help now
because the flash can just like run
really fast and if you were to just like
throw some ice on the ground he would
basically be dunzo there's only so much
you can do which is kind of like help
people Evacuate the area and so what
this is is it leads to like the rest of
the Justice League responding you get
one woman you get Supergirl which is
really dope how Jordan the Green Lantern
and then you get like hot girl who's
kind of cool sometimes I guess and then
you get like green arrow Oliver Queen I
don't even know what he's going to do
it's like when Hawkeye was in The
Avengers movie like I mean cool I guess
it's awesome that you're here but like
at the end of the day what are you going
to do aside from like trying to shoot
Loki and then basically failing
spectacularly but like everybody else
shows up right like the rest of the
league shows up but that's when you
start to realize the scale of what's
going on now some of these things I
recognize and some of them I don't right
you got like a giant spider that's over
there in Central City you got a woolly
mammoth that's in themos skira of course
you got Godzilla in Metropolis Hell's
Bells they even got a giant bat in
Gotham City right I mean just just so on
the nose DC right I mean you could tell
they're having a blast writing this and
so at this point like you basically have
like the bat family that responds right
like Batman Robin Jason Todd Nightwing
you get Batgirl Barbara Gordon who's
kind of cool and even like cyborg says
he's going to show up which I guess rahu
right like the Justice League's very own
walking talking iPhone is going to save
the day I guess and then like Black
Canary shows up now I wouldn't make fun
of Black Canary here but she actually
has a dope moment in this story it's
ridiculously cool right so at that point
what you end up getting here is Superman
who basically goes back on the offense
with like Godzilla and then you have
like Haw girl who shows up and like
tries to Pummel this guy as best she can
but one of the funny things about this
is learn incredibly fast Godzilla is
extremely fast right much faster than he
appears to be and of course given his
size and his just durability he's
incredibly strong as well now before we
get to the Superman segment we actually
end up jumping over to like Gotham City
with a giant bat because this section is
pretty awesome right you of course have
Kate Batwoman who's here do not let her
fool you man Batwoman is amazing I love
Batwoman in in DC Comics right now she's
never been cooler than she is right now
in DC Comics it's pretty solid but for
the most part they don't really know
exactly how to handle this kind of
situation and it makes perfect sense
it's one of the reasons why I love this
if it came to like Twoface right Solomon
Grundy any of those guys that like the
bat family would more or less know how
to handle that because like they face
them over and over again a gigantic bat
that quite literally looks like it flew
out of hell is not something that they
face off against regularly not only that
it's got a Sonic scream so like it's
enough to actually take out the bat
wings that they have now while all this
is going on of course collateral damage
right like debris falling on people and
all that kind of stuff and because I
cannot be a superhero in this inst that
I just I'd be like hey look man I mean
it sucks to be you guys debris falling
on you I don't know what to tell you
right we got like more important things
to focus on than that the bat family
decides to be superheroes and they more
or less go around trying to rescue
people where they can when they can
anybody who's been a part of this
channel long enough will tell you I
would be a villain if I got powers I
would absolutely be a bad guy but you
get this amazing moment with Jason Todd
now Jason Tod for those of you guys who
were unfamiliar with his character he is
very much this just kind of vigilante I
don't mind killing people type of guy
right kind of the antithesis to Batman
right where Batman's like sure we could
kill the Joker and spare Untold lives
that the Joker will probably end at some
point in the future but I cherish my no
killing rule I don't care how many men
women and children have to die in order
for me to keep it and so what ends up
happening is like they tell Jason Todd
do not pull the trigger because he's
there with probably the biggest and most
amazing gun that I've ever seen and he's
got like this just giant thing in his
sights and he's like all I have to do is
pull the trigger man and it's dunzo but
to their credit the concern of the bat
family is if you shoot this thing one we
don't know if you'll kill it and two if
you do we don't know where it's going to
land what happens if it lands on like a
skyscraper and kills thousands of people
right like is that really worth the risk
but in the mind of Jason Todd it's if we
don't kill it thousands of people are
going to die anyway right so I mean hey
you know like six in one hand half a
dozen in the other right might as well
just take this thing out and so what he
ends up doing is firing off the shot
against the objections of everybody
Batman Nightwing the whole nine yards he
fires it off it doesn't kill him this
whole area gets blasted he survives but
then they just kind of start screaming
at him for what it was that he did but
while this is going on right cyborg
arrives just in time right like the
iPhone arrives just in time I'm G start
calling him iPhone from right now and he
shows up and basically puts together
what isn't effect a Sonic amplifier for
Black Canary because what they're going
to do is they're going to just like
Jerry rig this thing to a Batwing and
fly up and use it and it's amazing
because like when they do they kind of
get the attention of like this giant bat
and that's when they make their move
right they literally go flying up to
this thing Black Canary screams into the
Sonic amplifier like in this thing's
face right and just completely and
totally overwhelms it and seemingly
either knocks it unconscious or kills it
we're not really giving a definitive
answer here but that's when you jump
back over to Superman and Godzilla
alongside Haw girl and the fight between
these guys man it is knock down drag out
because Superman's realize quick fast
and in a hurry one Godzilla is
incredibly powerful and two it'll kill
him if it gets the chance which I was
never the biggest fan of Godzilla until
I met Mariah and she was like sometimes
Godzilla's a good guy sometimes he's a
bad guy sometimes the plot of any one
particular Godzilla movie is that he
shows up and just kind of like smacks
Humanity around a little bit just to
remind them who's in charge and then
just goes back into the ocean again and
like that's it that's the plot of of the
movie and that's kind of what's
Happening Here Right like Godzilla is
showing up and just kind of being like
just so you guys know right and just
kind of smacking Superman and these guys
around right just kind of establishing
his dominance which is pretty awesome if
we're being honest with ourselves but
again they do what they can where they
can but Haw girl is smacked Away by
Godzilla's hand only to be rescued by
Shazam yes son Billy Batson has arrived
on the scene and it's cool because it's
like having two Supermen that are
basically facing off against God right
now and that's what's so awesome is
because while this is happening Godzilla
son son son Godzilla starts to charge up
people Godzilla starts to charge up you
guys know how it is you guys know how it
is
that you guys know how it is it's
revving up and then it's just like bow
and then just like the atomic breath
just gets blasted at the same time
Superman fires off its heat vision it's
a standoff son it is a standoff between
Godzilla and Superman firing off their
energy towards one another even Shazam
is looking at this like dude this is
amazing right like this is the coolest
thing but what he does like Shazam comes
up with an idea right he ends up flying
over to Godzilla lands on his head and
then just shouts Shazam and then like
the lightning comes down it hits Shazam
but then it also hits Godzilla at the
same time it was kind of foolish right
it was a relatively foolish thing
because he could have gotten himself
killed and in fact even when he's
reverted back to like Billy Batson right
like the little kid he's just like that
was awesome because I mean let's be
honest with ourselves guys like we would
have reacted the same
way I would have been like yeah
superpowers but like it's it it was cool
like it's a really really cool thing but
even Superman kind of yells at him right
he was like it was too risky don't do
that again but the problem is in this
moment when they're flying away
Godzilla's Like Son all right look it
was cool and it was fun before and
you're adorable Superman you're so cute
with your cape and your magic underwear
you're so adorable but like I'm done
playing games right when you mess with a
bull you get the horns so what does he
do fires off that Atomic breath bam
Superman gets the Run of it goes
crashing down to the streets of
metropolis Billy Batson is just left
there Superman's totally unconscious and
like a boss the Beast the Beast known as
Godzilla is just roaring in the
background why my friends because he has
just dominated the Man of Steel with
that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching I will catch you all later
peace